[موسيقى]
عن ثلاثين عاما من اتفاقيات اوسلو التي
اصبحت ان نموذجا للفشل هذا ما يكتبه
دانيال ليفي رئيس مشروع ابحاث مركز ابحاث
الشرق الاوسط الامريكي والمفاوض السابق في
اوسلو وفي طابا وهو يقول بان
فيما متى يعرف بمرحله ما بعد اسلو بقي
امام الفلسطينيين اليوم هو ليس الدفاع عن
الارض او ما تبقى منها وانما الدفاع عن
الحقوق وعن الحريات في وجه التمييز
العنصري وان تحرر الفلسطينيون الفلسطينيون
من هذا فان الاسرائيليين ايضا يتحررون من
تمييز عنصري يقول اليهود الاسرائيليون على
حد تعبيره يتحررون من ادامه نظام عنصري
غير انساني مدمر للروح
وغير امن في نهايه المطاف في مجلات هذا
الاسبوع حديث اخر عن هذه العلاقه الفرنسيه
المغربيه التي اصبحت طلاقا بعد هدم تكتبه
مجله التي تعود على العلاقات الثنائيه بين
الرجلين بين رئيس
وبين الملك محمد السادس كل شيء او تقريبا
كل شيء يفصل بينهما تكتب هذه المجله بين
رئيس شاب مسرع يريد ان يحكم على جميع
النطاقات ومحكوم بصناديق الاقتراع في
جمهوريه خامسه لا يتعدى عمرها المائه عام
وبين ملك كهل لا يحب الحكم كثيرا بقدر حبه
للتصفار والتجوال خاصه الى خارج المغرب
ولكنه سليل السلاطين منذ العهد الثامن
الميلادي وهو اذا بالنسبه
للمغاربه ظل الله على الارض امين امير
المؤمنين المغرب تكتب المجله يرسل رساله
الى فرنسا وهو لم نعد بحاجه اليكم اليكم
رغم طول العلاقه التي تفصل بين البلدين في
موضوع اخر هذه المره عن العلاقات
المصريه الفرنسيه من زاويه اخرى
تعيد نشر هذا التقرير للصحفيه اغيان هذه
الصحفيه التي
اثارت اثار توقيفها واستجوابها لمده 48
ساعه من طرف المديريه العامه للامن
الداخلي الفرنسي الصدمه لدى الفرنسيين وهي
سابقه من نوعها قبل ان يتم اطلاق سراحها
تهمتها انها كشفت اسرارا توصف بسري دفاع
هذه الاسرار تتعلق بتزويد الاستخبارات
الفرنسيه
للسلطات المصريه بمعلومات استغلتها الس
المصريه لتصفيه معارضين مصريين تضامنا مع
اغيان لافخيوت تنشر لمونديبلوماتيك هذا
التقرير حول دور المؤسسه العسكريه في مصر
التي تستحوذ على شريان الاقتصاد المصري في
كفه المجالات من مجال البناء الى مجال
المعلوماتيه حتى وصولا الى رغيف الخبز في
بلد يعاني فيه اكثريه من المصريين من
الفقر ومن العوز في مجلات هذا الاسبوع
ايضا حديث في هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه التي
اصبحت حرب استنزاف علينا ان نفكر في طريقه
للخروج من هذه الحرب وفي سيناريو اخر لان
سيناريو الهجوم المضاد لم ياتي اكله قبل
حلول موسمي البرد وفي تكتب البريطانيه وفي
ديرش بيجل
الالمانيه حديث عن جذور هذه الحروه التي
تقول المجله بانها بدات العام 2008 عندما
تغيرت عقيده حلف شمال الاطلسي الى عقيده
التوسع بدل الدفاع وفي لبنان حديث عن
الصين التي تتجسس
بتتجسس على العالم في خدمه مشروعها لان
تصبح امبراطوريه عالميه نختم هذه المجلات
بهذا المقال عن الحكواتيين الفدوى في تونس
هؤلاء الذين نشروا الحليقيه في المغرب
والمدحين في الجزائر هؤلاء الذين نشروا
التراث الشعبي
المغاربي
ونشروا اساطير الاولين عن الفتوحات
الاسلاميه وعن الابطال
وكذلك لعب دورا كبيرا في احياء الثقافه
التراثي الشفوي في المنطقه المغاربيه
هؤلاء الذين تخصص لهم مجله
اذا
مقالا مستفيدا وتقول بانهم انقرضوا بوصول
مع وصول الراديو والى التلفزيون الى
المخيله الشعبيه هكذا اعزائي المشاهدين
ننهي هذه الجوله عبر المجلات قدمناها
لحضراتكم
[موسيقى]